as chair of the house ways and means
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
covert 19 pandemic
in accordance with the house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
autonomy
this is a works committee work session
please note that there is no physical
location of members of the public to
observe and listen contemporarily to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
audit i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporariously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has
access to contemporariously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by the zoom platformer by telephone all
necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules irsa
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271 3600 or email hcs
lake.state.nh.us in the event the public
is unable to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled i want to introduce the
staff that are
on the meeting assisting us christopher
cherry
and jen iv please note that all
votes that are taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote
i start the meeting by taking the roll
call attendance
when each member states that president
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting which is required under the
right to know law
uh representative bernstein you want to
take the role thank you mr chair
and good day to everyone it is march 30
103 p.m we'll begin our roll call with
representative
pat abrami uh alone and i'll i'll answer
uh representative elliot's question at
the end because we have
people waiting to testify today okay
representative mary griffin
representative griffin representative
hollery
representative owen representative russ
ober
you're in hudson with the five cats
there were six
last week no no only have five sorry
okay representative ducette
representative fred ducette your clerk
is alan burstein and i'm here in
nottingham new hampshire
in my home office by myself
representative
robert elliott here and my wife is in
the living room
representative i'm here in salem new
hampshire in my home office
and my wife is not here but may return
home at some point
representative herschel nunes good
afternoon mr clerk i am home alone in
pelham representative tim baxter
thank you mr clerk i'm home alone
representative walters pillsbury
good afternoon i'm home alone in
charlestown
afternoon representative tudor home
alone in northport
representative army home alone in
lebanon
representative ames yes i'm here
and jeffrey in my home office alone
representative southworth
here alone in dover representative
malloy
here alone in greenland representative
thomas schamberg
uh i'm enrollment in the basement my
wife's up in the office
hopefully she'll let you out real soon
representative tucker yes i'm here
in randolph where it's 55 degrees
and i'm alone good day to you
representative jenny gamarlo
i am here in swansea and my husband's
outside somewhere
representative tom laughman
representative laughman
representative amanda gorg good
afternoon i am
present and alone representative mary
hacken phillips
uh hello i am coming to you from my
office in concord alone
representative james murphy good
afternoon i am here alone in my home
office
in hanover our chairman representative
norman major
good afternoon i'm in my home office and
my wife is in the house
mr chair currently there are 20 members
present
four members are awol
i haven't heard that word for a while
yeah
all right
this is just a more of an informational
meeting and then we can discuss some
bills
but i sent you probably about an hour
ago or an email
which is the status of our bills
and essentially
we've had a total of 38 house bills
sent to us this session so far
of that 15 of these bills
we retained and solicited in the email
that i told you
sent to you
and then there are 14 bills that were
off to pass or opt to pass with
amendment
you know those bills 14
six of six of them have already been
taken care of
in the last seven
the committee has voted to itl
2 bills house bill 8 181 and
528 and we vacated one bill to municipal
county government
and we've received to date six senate
bills
we've acted on three senate bills last
week
and we have three senate bills left to
be acted on
that senate bill
22 27 and 103.
now coming up next week
we have
eight bills
on the calendar of the eight bills we
have on the calendar
we have four bills on the consent
calendar
that's hospital 533 565
610 and 615. so that leaves four bills
on the regular calendar that
those four bills enlisted the
bills that are on consent calendar are
pulled off
but you can expect that the four
bills on the regular calendar will be
debated
cacr 1 cacr2
house bill 15 and house bill
626 house bill 15 is the one that has to
do
with the facilitators
the room and car rentals
and house bill 626 has to do
with the horse racing
machines
now before we started representative
elliot had started a discussion on house
bill 626
and we can continue that discussion
representative romney you want to
respond to what
representative elliot questioned those
i have the highest regard for uh
representative kirk
but you gotta understand about
representative kirk he's never
he's never supported any any gaming of
any kind
over the years uh it's interesting that
he's defending the honor of of
establishments to
put these braces in even though he's
really against
the whole idea so
when this bill came out a couple years
ago wasn't originally my bill
uh the idea came out for historic racing
churchill downs who owns
who owns oxford casino threatened
to open a whole bunch of these terrible
locations
with just these machines in them as a
way of preventing that
we put a a kind of a freeze period of
three years in the bill
so that that wouldn't happen so that you
had to be
a ongoing concern uh we didn't want to
open
with charitable with the historic racing
machines and having new establishments
open with these machines
in them uh just for the purpose of of
that
of having those machines so that's why
it was originally in there but
when you when you look at it now it also
gives
communities having to do with the opt-in
stuff
it does give communities new communities
without historic without charitable
gaming
to look at but they want to zone
the way they want a zone if they don't
want a charitable uh
location in their town um that that'll
give them some time to do that
so um
what can i say that's kind of the
history of it uh
and during this period during this
initial period
anybody who wants to open a charitable
location
can do so it isn't saying to anyone that
they cannot
not open their 16 locations currently
uh it's open to anyone who wants to open
a business
we're not stop we're not stopping them
to to do that
but we're just putting uh but if you're
a new location
where we're putting a a pause of three
years
to make sure that they are indeed
a reliable a terrible location
uh with all the other games
without without these machines and then
once they prove themselves
then then they um can go forward
and and bring these machines in that's
basically the logic
and this was in the bill we discussed
this in committee uh there's nothing new
here um
the and the hypocrisy of it all
is that neil kirk my friend
has a website out there that
um is you know fighting against this
but i have found out that that website
is paid for by churchill downs
um and churchill downs is opening
they're renovating a facility in
kentucky right now that they own uh
to have live racing and to put 1500 of
these
machines in in that and the reason being
because
the horse racing people know that horse
racing is too slow for the young crowd
this is half an hour between races
is is just too boring so
um so what they're doing their strategy
is to use these same exact machines
that they're paying to fight against
this bill
okay and they're putting the same
machines in in kentucky
1500 machines in this facility uh so
i mean this is what this is what we've
been fighting here in this bill all
sorts of misinformation
um and that's all i can say it's getting
a little frustrating actually
thank you representative
thank you mr chairman and i do not know
if churchill downs is paying for
representative kirk's website
it would be nice if you're going to make
accusations like that to have
evidence i have been the subject of
accusations for years now that were
spoken out loud
that on that the coalition against
expanded gambling which had various
names over the years
on was getting money from places like
casinos when we were not
are not and would not
on and it would be
um it would talking about hypocrisy
to take away the option from the
communities that have already been
a poker place put into it
on which is now going to blossom into
machine gambling in communities that
did not want that who are required to
take it
and there are many small communities
that refuse to have zoning so they will
be helpless against this
also and um
i i just i object thank you
representative ames
thank you um you know
the first thing i want to say is that
i'm a little troubled by having this
discussion
i don't think this was um the meeting
was was noticed to discuss
bills that remain before us and um
revenue issues so i don't really
understand this
being a subject of discussion i guess i
i want to say on what is being discussed
that um the
if there's any implication that
opposition
to this bill can be based on the merits
or demerits of the bill and nothing else
then
i i i reject that
i i'm opposed to the bill because of
what's in it
and as everybody at least who was around
eight years ago no i chaired a
commission
that put together a bill that proposed
the startup of a single large
casino and uh so you know i don't
i i'm interested in the merits of a
proposal i think the merits of this
proposal
are lacking and that's why i've opposed
it i'm not going to go further with that
i think we've you know i we've discussed
this
and we'll discuss it we'll debate it on
the floor the bill's
in-house bill 2. so we'll probably have
a debate
in that context before we even reach the
bill
that's come through this committee
because it's the same bill
the same text that's in house bill 2.
so i look forward to that debate and
we'll
see what happens and as far as churchill
downs go
i have no relationship whatsoever to it
and uh object to any implication that i
might have
okay um what i'd like to
do is later on
uh susan if we can get together
and agree to how many
we would like to have speak on each side
hopefully no more than two i hope
this is going to be very difficult
because it was
put by certain people
into hb2 and
so there will be two debates
i do not understand why our bill isn't
being
retained or something in this case but
probably it's too late to do it
um but on i have to consult with all
sorts of different people
about this now because it's in two
places
and i don't know when we're going to
finish trying to figure things out
thank you well thank you
um
and representative ames you're right
it wasn't noticed for this discussion
but this discussion started with mr
when representative elliot had his
question
and i felt since he brought up the
questions might as well
get the answers um
anything else new
on this part of the discussion
representative
abram i just want to say that in no way
was i
when i mentioned churchill downs was i
implying anyone on this
uh committee had anything to do with
churchill downs
i just wanted to say that i didn't say
that either
now what i do want to say about these
bills
is that i will be contacting
representative later find out
who she has lined up
on these for a bill
and is there you know
anybody is going to take off
any of the ones that we have on consent
to be to debate
so that we can line up the debates
i do have a question representative
major
i i've heard and maybe it's official
that the
bills are going to be ordered in a
different way than
is customary so that uh the ought to
pass
motions will uh precede the itl motions
is that
correct that's what we heard
is they're going to concentrate
wednesday on house bill
1 2 and 25.
25 is the bill has to do with
all the
construction etc and then
on thursday second day
concentrate on all the ought to pass
bills
and then friday the
itls bills
and that's the we've been told now
if house bill 1 2 and 25 goes
quicker then they may start on the ought
to pass bills
on wednesday
but he plans to start at nine and go to
six or seven o'clock
wednesday night the same thing start at
nine
on thursday and go to six
at seven and then the same for friday
but i'm hoping that we can finish all of
our work in two days but it depends on
what we want what the reps want to do
most people have made up their mind
if you're going to talk on a bill i
would limit it to
important points no more than three
minutes or
because we're on for one look
everybody turns out and and let's get
this thing over with
your points let the next ones fake make
your points
but don't go on for 15 to 20 minutes
we'll we're never getting done
just keep my fingers crossed hope that
things can go smoothly
everybody can have their say those pros
and cons
that's why we're here
and they should have been having this
say all along to convince people even
before we go to get to the session
uh representative thank you i just
wanted to point out that
hb 15 which i had forgotten about
actually
on has two people who voted against it
one republican and one democrat
yes so i haven't been considering that
something that i would have to recommend
somebody to speak
for i'm hoping that
we can agree on that well let's talk
let's talk after you've had an
opportunity to check with your caucus
i'm planning to hold a republican caucus
tomorrow
at 11 o'clock oh let me tell
talk about tomorrow
jennifer has come through again because
i've asked her to
do what she could to find some expert
out of washington
that understands the stimulus bill
and what it means to the states
what they can't and can't do
and so she's as arranged
to have a mrs emily brock
emily brock is the director of the
government
finance office association and
they are there in order to provide
information to the states on
the effect of the government legislation
so you should have received now and
think about
her slides about 15 slices or so
you might want to review those because
she's going to be here for about
virtually
for about an hour 15 minutes starting at
nine o'clock tomorrow
it'll give us an opportunity to
interface
with her to ask questions we need to
know what we can and what we can't do
with this relative to revenues
also nice to know about the
appropriation part of it too
so and i've also sent word to
senator geider who's chairman of the
senate
ways and means senator
the chairman of the senate finance
committee
and ken weiler who's chairman of the
house finance committee
if they want to or any of their members
and so far looks like the two chairmans
from the senate
will be joining us virtually on this and
they'll
be able to ask questions as well as
as our committee so it should be very
interesting
i hope it does what we
would like it to do so we can understand
it
that's tomorrow and then so we should be
through about 10
30 4 11 and then 11 o'clock i'm doing a
whole
caucus of the republicans
and then as of this
point in time the final decision
tomorrow
looks like we may not be meeting on
thursday
i set these meetings just to have
placeholders in case
something happened and we needed to
respond and i don't see that yet
so it looks like
now we may not be meeting on thursday
but we will be meeting tomorrow morning
uh representative bromley
yeah i was going to say something about
these bills that we have to debate but
let's hold up can we discuss that later
uh when we're done with the hearing of
the work sessions on these bills because
we do have people waiting
okay
we have three bills three senate bills
that we haven't acted on and and
i expect we're going to get more senate
bills i haven't been informed within
that
and representative elmi has looked at it
and
also i think she agrees too
you were set
an email relative to information that
charlie mcintyre wanted
the committee to have on senate bill 27
and sally mcintyre is
he in the attendees right now i
just promoted him okay good thank you
charlie wanted to talk to the committee
about
senate bill 27.
the only action we've had is that we
ought to pass on three senate bills
and we also heard the other three senate
bills but we did not act on them
so instead of bill 27
is relative the sale of lucky seven
tickets
so charlie you had information you
wanted to share with the community
i do good good afternoon mr chair
members of the committee thank you
charlie mcintyre executive director of
hampshire lottery
the commission had been contacted by a
charitable trust in the state of new
hampshire
which is the charitable division of
great new hampshire restaurants
which owns a number of facilities in the
state uh cactus jacks
copper door num many restaurants and
they run a charitable
operation called feed new hampshire.org
which is respon which is
uh interested in feeding the hungry in
the state they are a charitable trust
and they're not with the secretary of
state so they don't comply with the
statute
but they like to avail themselves of
charitable gambling revenues
to assist the state in charitable
efforts
uh and i believe also on the call today
mr chairman is
the pri point person from feed new
hampshire.org
named tanya rudolph and so we drafted
language and forwarded to you
um to create sort of an exemption
for organizations that are
filed with the ag's office charitable
trust division but are not with the
secretary state
so that's the genesis of the request uh
it was based on a request that we had
received
uh and happy to answer your questions or
turn the floor over to whoever you want
mr chairman
so that's the language that you show in
your email
which is in italicized
letters
an applicant who does not make the
definition of a charitable
organization and then you have a b and c
yes exactly okay does everybody have a
copy of that
no no okay
i received it i received it yesterday
me too
um i have a question of uh to follow up
if i could
um and the question is well let me back
up
we do have a bill that we've retained
it's a house bill
it was uh filed by representative ulery
and it's 364 and
it expands the definition of charitable
organization
to include food fraternal organizations
and the way it was done was to reference
uh several irs sections for tax
exemption
so i just wanted to point that out and
then
my question is is there an exempt status
for
a trust such as this that's in the
internal revenue code
um thank you question representative not
that i'm aware of
i mean for our purposes the tax code is
really just a reference point
um if that makes sense i don't really
view the
a charitable entity could it could be
both could be exempt under irs or be a
charitable trust or both
um so i i don't think that's it's just
positive
well i'm not i'm not suggesting this is
positively asking
360 has to do with funding sources for
domestic
violence programs did i i said 364.
no oh 360. okay
yeah i do that too
representatives i think i've received a
note i think it has to do with raffle
specifically
and not charitable gambling in this
context
so it'd be raffles that you would apply
for a city or town for
versus through us
i guess uh a comment is the uh well
we're waiting for the chair
the um i think one of the reasons that
the ir internal revenue code is
referenced
is that it's it's
it's a way of ensuring the charitable
purposes of an organization and
if we don't have that i guess you would
say
that in this situation we have the
um let me find your memo we have
the attorney general's office
involvement
as a way of providing that but i guess
i'd like to know more
about what the attorney general needs to
find
to make that affirmation
charlie are you familiar with 364.
um i am not briefed on it for today
purposes but yes
it is titled expanding the definition of
charitable
organizations to include fraternal
organizations for the purpose of holding
raffles
it sounds like reptilians
makes a good point we retain that
yes
and would that amends actually if you
would
mr chairman if you let me um valerie
king is on if you would let her in she's
texting me notes related to statutory
interpretation
because that amends a different statute
it demands 287a
we mean would you like yup just promoted
her
valerie muted hi hi um
so the reference to the change in the
different irs uh designations is for
amendments to rsa287a which is the
raffle
statute the lottery does not regulate
the raffle statute that is regulated by
the city or town in which the
raffle drawing takes place so that has
no
bearing on the games of chance
statute which is rsa287d
in rsa3767d
rsa 287d is games of chance
rsa287a is raffles
okay and senate bill 27
deals with rsa287
it deals with rsa 287 d and rsa 287
e which is games of chance bingo and
lucky seven
those are our charitable games raffle is
not considered a charitable game under
lottery
so what i don't have the statute in
front of me but what what
is the definition of a charitable
organization under
under 287 c that's the right one um do
you mean 287 a the raffles
no moving off from that raffles the
applicable
statute 287d
which is what we're talking about right
now is a charitable organization
means this is what it currently says
um do you want what it currently says or
what is planning to okay
currently says means a bonafide
religious
charitable civic veterans or fraternal
or church
organization include including police
and firemen's organizations
which shall have been registered with
the secretary of state
for at least two years um and doesn't
and then it goes on to talk about it
doesn't include
auxiliaries okay
so i think that is different from the
bill we've retained so
then bring it
sp 27 would be okay
would you say i don't i don't know the
uh
i don't really know charitable trust but
the string of of uh
i guess i guess i'd like to understand
why this is not included or
if it's not included
we don't have information in front of us
okay representative
mary hackton phillips mr chair i
um representative ames i had similar
questions so i did the deep dive on the
rsas
um um i felt
that there might be just a suggestion to
valerie or
to charlie folks over the lottery
um in the proposed language it looks
like you misquoted the subsection for
charitable organizations
your language says rsa 287-d
colon 1 roman numeral 5 but that's
actually the
wrong subsection it should be roman
numeral four
for charitable organizations uh i
believe if i didn't
i'm looking at the most accurate um
uh bill for 287d on the general court
website
um but then i guess my other question
about
this in general was that you know i
think it's interesting that
if you go and look at rsa um
uh 7 colon 21 it looks at the definition
of
what a charitable trust is um and it
looks like it's swooping up that kind of
irs
3 code
in terms of the kinds of charitable
organizations and purposes
um so i think i think you know my only
question is
the language seems okay on its own to
include charitable trust but
you know my my overall question is how
many charitable trusts do not fit into
the category of terrible organizations
that exist now and if we open the door
here is it really a floodgate or is it
really just one
a one-off kind of new hampshire feed is
the only
trust that's not fitting in to this
category
so to answer your question
representative thank you um that it
you're correct there was a typo
the correct subsection you cited is
accurate accurate it was a
transposition error on the email uh as
for
the floodgate it's certainly in my time
this is the first time that i've been
approached by a charitable trust
as to applying for this so
i don't imagine it's a floodgate i can't
say for certain uh
valerie you you predate my time here so
what do you think
um i have we haven't run into this
situation before i can't
say what will happen in the future but
this is the first request that we've had
just as a quick follow-up um if i could
just
give everybody a little notation to
check on their own
it's rsa 7 colon 21
it defines charitable trust
and then speaks about what a charitable
organization would be
as well and it's clear that there is a
delineation
charitable organizations have 501 c 3
status
but charitable trusts do not so
the tax exempt status seems to be part
of the reason why they were excluded
possibly in the past um
and then it also talks about section 170
of that
inner internal revenue code um
terrible organizations that get
deductions but they're not
charitable deductions so it's just an
interesting kind of
um note that our existing law has
already kind of considered this
but in the past we excluded them so i'm
wondering if
there's something we're not putting
together
that we should be cautious about
including them suddenly so
for my two cents thank you mr chair
there is enough problems with this right
now
that we need to go into a have
since we have not many bills committee
as a whole
work session to iron this out
and that's what we were doing senate
bill 27.
[Music]
okay we have two other senators
andrew what's in it
uh i am wondering if the reason
that they have not become a 501c3
is that the charitable trust is partly
in order to to
provide for the prosperity of cactus
jackson the copper door
which would probably disqualify them
from
from the 501c3 category i don't know
i do know that there are people who have
abused 501c3
and have have done that and it
was illegal for them so um
they're being legal about this
um but the operation
it the charitable trust itself i am
positing may be on partly for the
purpose of spreading the reputation
of of the donors which um
is a perfectly valid thing to do but
that may be why
uh whenever they considered this before
they created a separate category
just thinking non-lawyer
we're not comfortable with the answers
at this point in time
represent romney followed by
representative bromley mr chair
yeah we have time uh we're not even a
crossover yet
uh and this is the senate bill so
uh i i really think we should work this
bill um
i think the major concern was what was
in these these uh
internal revenue codes uh what what kind
of organizations are we talking about
so i think that would be the first step
now normal times we would we would have
subcommittee that would roll up their
sleeves and uh
and dig into these things i mean we
could do this as a committee
uh but i think we i think i know i want
to understand what's in the current
you know why not let's do it now uh
you know the 501 sees you know three
four seven eight
nine ten and nineteen and then see how
that matches up with
charlie's police amendment um
[Music]
so i you know i think we just gotta roll
pick a point starting point and roll our
sleeves up and
and uh and work this
and then and then uh also i think rick
newman also had some suggested changes
as well
thank you mr chairman okay um
anybody else on comments otherwise
we're going to hold this for committee
as a whole
session and i'll probably draw
on a few of you to be the point people
on this
we have two other senate bills mr chair
can i just interject one more thing
yes representative i think on 27
uh since we passed the other build uh
roman
um
the section one of the bill
would automatically i think we just take
this out of 27 because we we already
uh changed the licensing dates of
charitable gaming
in another build so that that that's one
off the list and then there's three
other things that
that are in 27 that we need to work on
thank you but uh mr chair rick newman
was on the call i think he may be on uh
to discuss
his uh his amendment as well that i
think crossed a couple of these bills
just just want to make you aware of that
thank you
thank you representative does he have
comments on this one
i think it covered a couple of the bills
i think it may be yes
[Music]
he's not in the attendees list okay
i made him aware of the meeting so he's
not there
okay thank you
okay um
one of the remaining two bills is senate
bill
22 relative to the sale of lucky seven
tickets
which is different from really the other
and this allows the play of electric
select e7 names sets the limit on
election seven deal size
and sets the maximum price per like to
seven tickets
and i do see rick newman testified the
last time on this
and he's not in the attendance list
do you know of anybody
that has any further information on
senate bill 22
representative browning the only other
one that contacted me
i think in opposition was uh tyler clark
i don't know if he's on
if he wants to speak he's also a
lobbyist
he's on and he did raise his hand
okay could you let him in
yep he's tyler you have
comments on senate bill 22 good
afternoon mr chairman can you guys hear
me
yes um i just want to quickly reiterate
that
i represent diamond distributors one of
the largest
paper lucky seven ticket distributors
in the state and we are opposed to
section one and section two of the bill
i do recall representative abrami asked
me about section three
um to which we would be willing to you
know work on an amendment with the
committee to bring back the 25 cent
ticket which we believe was an oversight
uh
last summer when the dollar ticket was
introduced through omnibus legislation
the language that was adopted did kind
of get rid of 25 cent tickets at that
time
but we are opposed to sections one in
section two
in my testimony to the committee i i
stated that
removing the paper ticket
being dispensed out of these electronic
gaming devices
further blares the line between a lucky
seven dispensing device
and a slot machine and i did send the
committee
after my testimony a copy of the
superior court's ruling on these
machines in
in why these rules were put forward that
in why it states in law
you know that they shall not be in the
nature of a slot machine
and i also included i believe the
legislative history for
house bill 348 from session year i think
it was 2010
2011 which gives you the
uh the timeline of the adoption of that
language
in the in that's the bill that was put
forward
that now provides us with language that
states shall not be in the nature of a
slot machine
and i'll also point out in the house
version of house bill 348 from that
session year
um the house adopted language that
actually banned
these electronic lucky seven machines
and the senate removed
that language
representative
thank you um so my
question is is about the paper and uh
what what purpose do you think the
the paper aspect of these machines
serves
[Music]
is there a purpose served by these apart
from dropping out the bottom of the
machine and
exactly what is it my understanding is
that the
outcome of these uh what they are is a
digital version of an instant lucky 7
ticket
the outcome is to be displayed on the
screen and also
on the ticket that comes out of the
bottom
the ticket plays the role as it it's
supposed to differentiate these machines
from
electronic gaming devices in
in the superior court ruling that i sent
to the committee which was also
affirmed by the supreme court
that the ticket
must come out and and the reason is that
there was a manufacturer i forget the
name of them
that came into the state and they had a
product that would dispense these
these tickets and it would also display
the outcome on the screen
well there were no no rules that allowed
these machines to exist
so this manufacturing company petitioned
the charitable
gaming and in racing the
commission at the time so this is prior
to it going over the lottery
requesting rules to allow these machines
to be put into
you know like fraternal organizations
and
bingo halls and the commission at the
time refused to write
rules and then there was house bill 348
that was put uh forward i think it
fought the following year
which in the house version banned these
machines from even coming
into the state so the commission delayed
putting forward any rules well then
house bill 348 passed
but it passed you know with the senate
removing that language
in this new language that said shall not
be in the nature of a slot machine
so the manufacturers petitioned again
but this time to the courts
and the courts told the racing
commission racing and charitable gaming
commission that they had to go back and
write rules
to allow these machines but but the
rules didn't necessarily have to
say what the manufacturer wanted them to
say so that's when we got these devices
that were put forward in i think rules
in 2015
which just which said you had to uh
which were in line with the statute that
said you had to display the outcome of
the ticket on the screen and had to
shoot out a
ticket out of the bottom okay and that
was from being in the nature of a slot
machine
so if i may follow up
um yeah i'm still trying to understand
depart from that legal history
um what sort of functional purpose they
serve
they're kicking out the bottom of the
machine we've heard a lot of testimony
to the fact that nobody
looks at them and i'm wondering do they
slow down the game at all
do they affect the rate of play
um can you speak to sort of the function
played by these paper tickets apart from
dropping out the bottom so i've played
these machines and i think i might have
been the only person to ever take the
tickets out of the
out of the bucket that it comes that's
on the bottom that collects them
um the rate of play used to be five
seconds so every five seconds you could
tap the button
and it's my understanding and i don't
know the exact internal mechanisms of
these machines is that they print these
tickets
as you go through as you go through the
deal so it's printed on the fly
uh but the rules adopted last summer
i actually allow these machines to be
played every two and a half seconds so i
haven't played a machine since so i
could not tell you if it actually slows
the
machine down to a rate of play that's
slower than that to print it out
um but you know
the tickets serve the purpose of that
it's not in the nature of a slot machine
and yeah i understand that but we could
always change that language
um if that was the preference of the
committee
so it's important history but
it's not not apart
yeah i mean i'm yeah
our committee
there she goes okay so i that's
that's my question i think it's been
answered so i'm also thank you
okay um represent romney's followed by
uh you wait yeah gallery that
would go yes yeah i can wait
valerie um yes i just wanted to clarify
that the ticket printing has nothing to
do with in the nature of a slot machine
the the electronic machines are required
to print a ticket because the statute
says that lucky seven
has to be a dual uh paper
double-sided ticket you know a a break
open featured ticket
that's why the machines print a ticket
not because it's
would otherwise be in the nature of a
slot machine we've just
defined what in the nature of a slot
machine is
in our rules and we've defined it as
um it's not a random
a slot goes on random wins
and this is a defined deal with a set
number of winners and losers and
therefore
it is not in the nature of a slot
machine
thank you representative romney
so i got two questions one one on this
topic
so so what we're saying is that that if
we did away with the piece of paper
coming at the bottom
that we wouldn't be in violation of what
the courts said to do is that what i'm
understanding
uh tyler or valerie well start with
tyler
or valerie why don't you go ahead i'll
show your hand up
hey the um courts did not require us to
allow these machines
what it said was you can't deny
the manufacturer if you don't have rules
that say
what qualifies and what does not qualify
as an acceptable ticket
or a device so we had to
write rules that differentiated what is
good
and what is not good for um being
approved as a
lucky seven device okay so the answer is
we wouldn't be in violation of a court
order going way back when
is what what i'm hearing we would we
would not
be in violation okay so we we can go
ahead and do this if we wanted to okay
thank you
so i'm gonna go move to the uh uh
second uh mr chair can i move to the
second question i had unless you had a
follow-up mr chair
so you have your second question yes
on the second uh pay you know
lines 10 through 13 uh the second
section
so currently the the statute reads
a licensed distributor shall pay a fee
of 15
per deal of a pull tab of pull tab
tickets
so is that uh i'm gonna ask valerie this
question and you have your hand up
anyway
uh so that fifteen dollars is that
fifteen dollars go to the state
and uh is it for any size deal
currently
that's correct the deal fee goes to the
state and it is for
any size deal and we set the by rule we
set the deal size to a max of 3 500
tickets
okay and is that
is that why in this because now there's
a follow-up
in the bold right after the purr we now
see 3 500 tickets as the
or any portion thereof contained in each
deal well okay so are we just putting
that language in
uh because it was silent before and it
was in rules now we're putting it in the
bill
um by by adding that
words those words if we were to
increase the deal size under the current
statute
the state would lose money because we'd
get 15
whether or not it's 3 500 tickets or 14
000 tickets
i got it so by revising this we get 15
for every 3 500 or any portion thereof
right because okay thank you because
that was going to be my next question
is all right i wasn't reading this
correctly so
15 per five hundred tickets because the
real essence of this is that
the commission shall not authorize a
deal size the new pieces that we're
really saying the
uh the deal size can be up to fourteen
thousand tickets correct
that's correct that would be uh what uh
three deals
so we would get if if we did this
four deals i can't
yeah whatever yeah you're right four
deals
uh so we would get sixty dollars for
that okay
i just wanted to make sure that we
weren't still getting fifteen dollars
per deal for a fourteen thousand
ticket deal so and it's
my final question follow-up is
is this both for the pull tabs
the paper pull tab deals as well as the
uh machine deals
yes the the deal fee applies to all
deals regardless of whether or not
they're
um traditional paper or electronic okay
thank you
i'm set representative
thank you mr chairman i'm sorry i may
possibly have missed this question
when i was being called by some one of
the people that i have to talk to in
order to
for us to finish figuring out what we're
doing next week
on and but
as i understand it the lottery by
itself has increased the permissible
uh size of the deal to 14 000 tickets by
combining deals
and the lottery by itself
has increased the the
speed of play to every two and a half
seconds
and i want to know if there is any
functional difference
as versus behind the scene that no
player can see
difference between these and slot
machines now
and why why we're just playing games
with this we're doing it with the
historic
racing machines we're doing it with
these they can compete with each other
uh but these are all over the place
and um this
15 years ago or so they changed
on they put put
heavy regulations related to jail cars
so jail car could stop
things like this and i'm a little
appalled thank you
valerie you want to respond to that
i'm not exactly honestly i'm not sure
which question
i'm answering um with with regard to
the the first part about the um
the the two seconds we have reduced it
down to two seconds that's from the time
the ticket
starts to complete reveal it has to have
two second pause so that the player can
actually know what the ticket reads
before it goes to the next one
that it doesn't sound like a lot of time
but it actually is a lot of time
could you tell me how often you can push
a button on a slot machine these days
i i don't regulate slots i don't know
anything about slot machines
they aren't something that i am familiar
with
and you also represent me
and the the the deals were also combined
so that you could have 14 000 tickets
at a time and nobody would
would know whether you'd won all of the
the uh prizes or
so what we did um is we did allow four
deals to be sold
at the same time this is something that
is commonly done
even before we put it in regulations
when um
a fraternal home may have like a
fishbowl where they put a bunch of
tickets in a bowl and people just pick
them out and
and buy a ticket through the fishbowl um
so we basically just allowed put in
regulation
that was allowed up to four deals at one
time can be sold in combination
are you all set represent me
at least i know
just want to follow up on that uh just
to make sure we all understand
so that's so that you just mentioned
paper tickets putting it in my bowl
uh it's four deals we still get 60 out
of that
as a state correct
that is correct okay but uh
and my understanding from last uh when
we first heard the bill
is that the electronic machines you can
do the same thing
you can you can combine deals on the
electronic machines as well and is that
happening
that's correct that's we put that in
regulations
to make sure that they were limiting it
to no more than
four deals at one time
right what would be the difference
between
what we're doing now i think it was
asked a minute ago but
what was what we're doing now what this
bill is
is saying um so currently
you have four deals they're made up of
no more than 3 500 tickets so there's a
certain set of winners and losers in
each of those deals
but you're limited on your prize
structures
if you're allowed to make a single deal
that has
a 14 000 tickets you're much
more able to create
honor games games with more prizes
different prize structures
it increases their um flexibility on
what types of games and offerings they
can provide
okay just trying to understand thank you
can the can the participants
want speaking mute their mics because
there's
a lot of static coming up
excuse me perhaps
this question could be answered by uh
representative abrami
i am wondering there's a lot of emotion
and misunderstanding and happening
i don't understand whether
representative abrami believes that
it's now easier for people to
get into this whether they're going to
be more or less
winners or losers what what is
what is the direction of all these
questions and these numbers
i don't sort of get it in a context i
don't gamble
i had never been to a machine i don't
understand what we're really talking
about i'm sorry and perhaps
you could just make a
sentence or two is to are we talking
about making it
easy just to take money from people who
are
gambling or making it more favorable to
the state what is the
thrust of these changes
yeah i'm just trying to learn about this
bill this is not my bill
uh uh what i was trying to understand is
is
it it sounds like we're already doing
these things
and it looks like we're going to put
into statute it may be
a little uh what what's already
happening
uh but i was trying to also get at what
i want to make sure
that what's happening now uh the state
isn't going to isn't going to get isn't
getting less money than
what the bill says and it sounds like
it's going to be identical
the 15 per 3 500 tickets
uh but let me i do have another question
just maybe think of another question i
just can't help myself
but that's all i'm trying to do here uh
trying to understand
uh where are we where are we now
and what does this bill do that we
aren't doing now and
what does it mean to the state revenue
so your questions really are the same as
mine
yeah okay so do you have any
have you learned something in the last
10 minutes that yeah well i'm just
clarifying my own mind
i mean that's uh i'm just clarifying
where we're at what's in these i'm not
quite sure
how much way i'm voting on these either
uh other than the
the last section which i was going to
raise my hand again i do support putting
making sure we put the 25 uh ticket back
in
yes um so i i don't want to say that if
even if we don't go with the first two
sections i think we
saved the third section is my that's my
preliminary feeling but
uh we need the community to keep on
discussing this
how everybody else feels about the first
first and second section
so are you all set representative tucker
i am thank you
representative phillips
are you muted sorry thank you mr chair
i have a question for the lottery
commission um
i was just reading through rsa 287
uh dash e in regards to distributors and
manufacturers of bingo supplies and
equipment
it states here that um all lucky seven
vending machines sold
leased or rented in the state are
licensed
and that the distributors have to hold a
license for lucky seven
tickets in order to distribute
the bingo paper supplies or electronic
bingo player systems
and lucky seven vending machines so my
question is
if we remove the paper ticket
does that mean that these people would
not need to be licensed
no they would still need to be licensed
they are distributing
um bingo and lucky seven products and to
do that you need a license
you need a license distributor and the
manufacturers need to be licensed as
well but
it says here in this section that
there's a fee for the paper
is that something that would no longer
be applicable
if they were not using the paper
um if you're referring to the deal fee
it's based on the deal so a deal
is says regardless of whether or not
it's paper
or electronic okay i'm not i'd have to
look to see exactly what section you're
looking at
if there's something if that's something
different than what
i'm thinking of okay i was looking at
section 287-e colon8
a but um
yeah it looks to me that there's not
only a fee for a license but also
possibly a fee related to the
paper supply for these machines and i'm
just wondering if we
get rid of the tickets does that mean a
loss of revenue of some sort
section 8-a is just
regard to their license fees
um so that's really the five ten
thousand dollars for the distributors
that's
for the right to distribute to
distribute the
the bingo and lucky seven products um
it has nothing to and then they have to
have a fifty thousand dollar bond with
the state but that doesn't have anything
to do
with um whether or not they sell paper
or not
okay thank you
okay any more questions to ask in the
charlie or valerie
i don't see any hands up
all right so then we'll hold this for a
future work session we're not going to
have
any work sessions until after next week
when we
finish our regular session
a third bill senate bill 103-fn
relative to nexus provisions for certain
disaster-related or emergency related
work
performed in the state
what are some of the questions that
committee members have
on this
representative major
i think we were told that the dra
has possible concerns and a
perhaps a corrective amendment um
that's what i've jotted down here
beyond that i know nothing
it says indeterminally negative on
retinals
mr chair i know dra is on this call um
and they i uh it has to do with the fact
that this is a generic bill
that uh every state's it's been moving
around the states and about
i don't know 30 i don't know what number
about 30 the states have adopted this
but since we have a unique tax structure
that perhaps
passing it as boilerplate when it comes
to there's personal taxes
in here and things like that i think the
ra would just want to address some of
that
and they are on the call i don't see
anybody in there
representative major i already promoted
carol and lear to pin carolyn
senate bill 103.
good afternoon representatives this is
carolyn lear assistant commissioner
at the new hampshire department of
revenue
um
we do we have um our fiscal impact
statement
um as part of the bill package that you
have i think that is pretty
self-explanatory um
what this field does is um
create an exemption to
nexus for a business that is in the
state
to provide disaster related work
the bill provides that they won't be
subject
to any tax other than a transactional
tax
um a transactional tax is something like
a sales tax
such as our meals and rentals tax they
would still be subject to those sort of
transactional taxes but would not be
subject to business taxes and
therefore our fiscal note does note
um that there could be an indeterminable
uh decrease in revenue because if those
businesses are
responding to disasters currently
in the future those businesses would not
be subject to tax
and of course we have no real way to
actually pinpoint
the dollar value of that impact
the other thing i would know is that the
exemption applies only
to out-of-state businesses while in the
state
um in-state businesses remain subject to
the tax for providing the same services
although it's probably above my
expertise level to know whether that
would be a permissible exemption or not
but the one thing that i thought was a
bit notable from
the hearing and i didn't really clue on
to this until after hearing some of the
testimony on the bill
is that this bill
has sort of made the rounds in other
states
and most other states
have an income tax and so i think the
concern
from an emergency response type business
is that if they're going to send their
new jersey employee
to new hampshire for example there are
going to be
actual barriers related to
registering with the um
a different states department of revenue
to withhold
taxes for those employees and i
understood the testimony of
some of those in favor of this bill to
really be surrounding
withholding requirements in other states
and managing that
and i think that in and of itself isn't
as much of an
issue here in new hampshire where there
is no income
tax and no registration requirement with
the department of revenue
prior to coming into the state so i just
wanted
um to share that with you that i do
think it's
slightly different in new hampshire
because we do not have
a personal income tax oh carolyn
the bill as written do you see
anything in it that you're concerned
about
um i i don't think that i did from an
administrative
perspective um no i think we could
administer this bill um
just fine um i think the question of
whether the exemption
is broad or narrow enough um
to exempt only the intended activity is
really
a policy decision
thank you any questions for caroline
any further questions
i don't see any so
we'll close the work session on senate
bill 103.
uh i wanted to remind you about some
more at nine o'clock
we will be listening to
mrs emily brock who's the director
of the federal of the government finance
office association
talk to us on
how the stimulus effect
any other questions
mr chair yes yes pat can we go back to
the
uh four bills that are going to be
debated
for a minute we were talking about
earlier we done with all our bills now
mr chair we are done with all the house
bills i've received the last
birth today or last night and
sent that off to clark so
all of our blurbs are in
the four bills that we have to concern
ourselves with cac are one and two
and i want to talk to susan i i think
we don't need to have a full-blown
debate on this i think both sides are
dug in they know how they're going to
vote let's
make our statements and get on and vote
on
cicr one and two but uh
i'll discuss this with susan and see if
there is
others lined up
we were intending just to do on
one speaker each or one speaker each and
one pi
uh yes okay thank you
we were willing to go just the pis but
if you want to do one speaker each
that's fine too
okay then the other thing about it
is found host bill 15
which came out of our committee i
believe was 22-2
one republican and one democrat
do you have anybody lined up to speak in
opposition to hospital 15.
i told you on there was a
extreme minority in each party that
voted
against the majority on this bill so
it's up to the extreme minority to
decide if they're
talking
we know if he's is he i guess
is he going to be speaking enough
in opposition to house bill 15 on the
floor
i guess my question is to you mr
representative schomburg
let's go over to it i i put this
question to everybody
i haven't heard from anybody so i make
these
mr speaker mr chairman yes i'm in the
basement remember
my wi-fi okay yes i will speak on the
floor
okay thank you and i will do a pi sir
all right thank you sir you are welcome
so that takes care of that
the um
then the one
that's the most contentious of all four
which is house bill 626
here we have to determine how many are
going to speak in opposition
and how many are going to speak
in support of this bill and
do you have any idea susan at this point
i have no idea this is going to happen
twice apparently um
it's going to be debated on hope and i
have to discuss it with the finance
committee people
and they're busy and we'll see
how the finance does with hospital too
but making the assumption that
if it passes house bill 2
then somebody will probably end up
tabling it making a motion to table it
when it comes up for debate on the
regular calendar
then we'll have to figure out what our
strategy
would be
anything else
actually we're pretty lucky all right
cacr 1 and 2 is very clear
we know what the outcome is going to be
we also know it's terrible tax policy
because it requires something of future
legislatures for the next 120
200 years
you make a quick point
imagine there's good points on both
sides
and i don't disagree with you i mean on
the points
anything else from anybody
all right then uh we'll see you tomorrow
morning
at nine o'clock and this would be very
important
i would recommend looking through those
slides tonight
and get prepared for questions
i see no oh i i do see a hand
from um representative heck and phillips
mr chair i just wanted to notify you
that my conflict for tomorrow was
resolved
and i do anticipate being a participant
well thank you
all right then we're gonna
have a great evening thank you